foreign
you know how she does like because as
soon as we start thinking as soon as we
turn the ceiling fan on yeah she gets
like all talkative about it like she's
like look look the sand the Fan's on I
don't like it it's gonna fall on me and
then she just starts complaining
poor little baby I barely made the show
I was in there totally forgot I was
gonna do a show had to go run put pants
on because I yeah I had to put pants on
well I guess it's a good thing I got
like wearing shorts like wearing shorts
like 10 minutes before and it's like
because sometimes I usually just like
trust you to like look at the clock and
come in here when it's time but no I'll
get all wrapped up into something else
and just forget what the [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] I'm going I'll forget to the show's
even happening you forget your own name
you'll forget your identity
probably I don't know I'm speculating we
rewatched this episode
yeah it's really weird because I know we
watched this episode like recently
because remember we were doing because I
think we watched like a handful of them
like a month or two ago because we were
trying to decide which one to do and
this was one of the ones we were gonna
do and I could have sworn because when
we were first like watching it I was
like I could have sworn like I wrote
notes for this but I guess I didn't like
maybe I started writing notes and then
like we decided to do another show yeah
we watched we watched this whole one and
then we got done we're like this one
doesn't it's very vague there isn't a
lot of things that we know happened in
this story it's just kind of a vague
story if I remember correctly uh so we
decided let's not do this one let's do
another one I think that's what we
decided yeah because there weren't I
don't I I remember this not really
having any kind of like
hard facts to it unless I'm confusing it
with another one well this one is very
much like a possession type of story
and the thing about it is that there's
not like a lot of outside verification
or anything on it because the actual
woman that's at the center of it is in
Shadow like her and her sister on there
being interviewed but they didn't want
their real names used now there are real
people like John's office is on there
like you know we'll talk about him in a
minute and I think like the guy that did
the exorcism like Father uh L what the
[ __ ] was his name yeah I have a written
down somewhere but um Eldar Eldritch
something like that
um he's like yeah it's not that it's not
that it's like it starts but it starts
with the El though
um but yeah he was kind of like uh on
there too like talking for a few minutes
but I don't really know like what This
Woman's real name is yeah if I remember
thinking that there weren't any kind of
independent Witnesses and stuff with
this case it's like a good story but I
think the the when we looked at this we
were looking for a different kind of
case and we decided this wasn't like
what we were looking for I think well
like I said this is more like a straight
up possession story yeah like as opposed
to like a more haunted house style kind
of thing
Dave Rowling said the sister was about
to pill Cosby her possessed sister with
holy water in the iced tea for some
reason that really really made me laugh
like it issues I think I ever wrote my
notes of notes that she put some like
stealth holy water like an iced tea yeah
which is weird like why I don't
understand why she would do that because
like I mean we'll get to it but well
yeah but no but I mean the thing about
it was that the you know ostensibly
possessed sister like came in and like
tried to drink holy water like on her
own so why I didn't understand like why
the sister was trying to sneak I don't
know I don't get it we'll we'll get into
that in a little bit here I guess yeah
because I was like well that's what I
thought it was funny I was like why is
she doing that it's like you know she
tried to to drink the holy water before
just like right out the write out the
holy water little bottle right which is
funny I just I never thought about like
drinking holy water even though it's
obviously it's just water for Christ's
sake but I just thought it was like it's
like you're a demon though you know ah
it burns don't drink my holy water
now I gotta go like out of the [ __ ]
Cathedral and get some more you know
what a pain in the ass that is do they
have like big gallon jugs of holy water
I'm sure they must probably yeah like I
haven't even blessed all at once that's
what I'm saying and then it's just bust
yeah yeah because they just get the
priest in there and just like bless like
the whole tub full
so then they can just like scoop it out
I'm going to the church on the right in
the doorway I think there's a little
like cistern of it yeah yeah yeah
purify yourself yeah I don't know I'm
not a Catholic but I'm just saying yeah
like this is a very Catholic kind of
story well I always kind of wonder that
but then I don't know why I don't know
why that's so amusing to me but I was
thinking to myself yeah like not only
holy water like they'd have to have like
a constant supply of that but you'd also
have to have like the communion Wafers
right so they have to have like some
place that produces those and they have
to get like big shipments of them yeah
they don't taste good I've had them the
comedian Wafers well don't they just
kind of just taste like nothing it's
like a cracker they're not salted
I mean why don't they just use like
Nilla wafers or something no it's got to
be a cracker it's got to be a it's got
to be bread why don't they use good
bread
like why don't they use like some crispy
Focaccia or something yeah yeah you
think Jesus
they don't season it
because they like suffering and they
don't like Joy is that what it is it's
kind of like it's kind of like that
Yiddish
bread unleavened bread cracker you know
what I mean it's like a cracker without
any salt on it uh Jewish people know
what I'm talking about yeah what's I you
know what I know the name of that but I
fill up a fish on it or something it's
like that yeah it's what the [ __ ] is
that thing called uh
no uh I used to know the name of that
it's like that yeah I'll probably think
of it like in five minutes it's good
with something on it but they just put
it on your tongue it's just this ritual
ceremonial thing you know I know but
like I said If You're Gonna Go the whole
hog I mean you know the Catholic church
is like they they have like all these
pretty stained glass windows and all the
like pimping outfits and stuff like that
you'd think they could at least like
have some fancy [ __ ] comedian Wafers
yeah that taste like [ __ ] they can
make them little sliders they could I
mean you know get creative get creative
with the [ __ ] Jenny's doing doing
[ __ ] critiques on
Catholic ritual come on
say it I'm just saying there's there's
lots of ways you could go with it
granther says the church I was forced to
attend always served stale white bread
and grape juice instead of wine I was
robbed yeah I think a lot of churches
did back in the day that's what I heard
like I said I don't you know I didn't
grow up Catholic and I only knew like a
couple of people yeah it was it's called
matzos yeah that's what I thought it was
yeah right yeah that's like I suspected
that was right but then I was like well
maybe not
it's real thin and crispy
yeah like a Saltine cracker but thinner
you know what's weird you can buy those
at the grocery store yeah but you can't
buy communion way first almost kind of
like a big Pringle
if I remember correctly no it wasn't it
was more like a big Saltine cracker now
see that would make a good convenient
wafer yeah
well they could do the same thing like
they could make it like a pringle but
like not in the saddle shape they could
make it in the convenient way for sheep
yeah because that's just made of like
potato flakes that are kind of like
President the name of them is called the
holy
flavor is Holy Holy Pringles holy
I mean you know more people might go to
church then if you had like you know lay
out some dip you could have a whole
[ __ ]
you could have a whole [ __ ] party
tray going on
Mark says coming from a rural Irish
Catholic Family I can confirm in a
religious household the more holy water
the better yeah that's just uh that's
just kind of funny that like you'd
always have some holy water well I don't
know why like I said I guess because I
didn't grow Catholics so it wasn't I
didn't really know anybody that grew up
Catholic so it's like I'd seen it in
movies and [ __ ] but I just thought it
was funny that someone would like come
in someone else's house and be like
where's mom's holy water you know what I
mean it's like that was like really
really funny to me I don't know why I
don't know Donovan's gone it has a great
crutch I said yeah put you put like baba
ganoush on it
yeah yeah
Mediterranean food yeah that sounds good
actually grandpa says also my
grandmother always declined communion
looking back she was the secret apostate
sneaky
uh Danny Rowling said Jenny should drive
her Taurus like the mom in this episode
Drew hers and give Tom the ride of his
life
exactly that is exactly my same car
probably might even be the same it might
be the same year I have an old ass car
Florida has cooked the paint off of the
[ __ ] front my poor car trunk and the
[ __ ] Hood everything everywhere else
it looks brand new except the [ __ ]
all the clear coats paint has boiled off
the [ __ ] Hood yeah and then uh rust
has taken over the back of the dam
trunk it's a 2004 yeah I mean it's
almost 20 years and and repainting that
car I mean it's silver you know
repainted I don't think it'd be worth it
would be probably be cheaper just to get
a new hood and truck out of a junkyard
from another state that's silver and
just bolt that in place probably look
new again the car doesn't look old those
[ __ ] last forever you get in there
you get in it though and you realize how
dated the interior is versus other cars
yeah it's still got a cassette deck got
a cassette deck it's like going back in
time although you can like you can buy
these things because I bought one at um
what is that place like AutoZone or
whatever you can buy a thing that's like
a cassette tape but like you hook it up
to your cell phone and you can like play
music through there so that's what I was
doing for a long time but
it's funny but I don't use the car
enough anymore so I don't like I don't
have Pandora anymore or anything like
that but like that's what I rarely use
it
we rate yeah we basically only use it
like to go out a couple of times a month
and yeah that's it and every now and
then I drive to a grocery store or
Dollar General I'm like I could buy
another car but then I'm thinking like
that's just another bill that thing's
working yeah you know I computed it out
and I've thought that and and it made
sense to where it'd be cheaper to just
rent a car whenever you need never we
needed one they even have services that
they'll drive the rental to you yeah
usually Enterprise will do that I don't
know about the other ones but I know
I've had that yeah in the time I was
looking at that it was only like a
couple years ago it made it may have
changed now it would it would have been
cheaper for for us to just use rentals
because there's no worry about
maintenance or tires or oil change or
insurance I don't have to pay insurance
every month yeah which is bring me a car
I need a car overnight and then you know
it'd be about 70 or 80 dollars back in
those days I think and it would still be
cheaper than a car payment at the rate
that we were using it yeah because like
I said we really only use it
three or four nights a week a month yeah
and like it's nice to have like to drive
up to the grocery store now the Dollar
General is you could walk to that if you
had to but the I mean you could
technically walk to the Publix if you
had to but everything else kind of far I
could use motorcycles for a lot of stuff
too because I got motorcycles they're
all paid for that's true
that's true we just gotta get saddlebags
for them but the thing is is eat that's
shopping on a motorcycle is [ __ ]
crazy
yeah now if you had a trailer
hooked up a trailer hitch off the back
of the motorcycle they have those little
two-wheeled trailers
out of the motorcycles I have are not
great candidates for that but you can
shop at that
I mean I used to before I had a car
um I used to walk I lived within walking
distance to the grocery store but it was
still kind of a pain like because you
had to walk because you couldn't buy
like a [ __ ] ton of stuff and you had to
like bring stuff back like in a rolling
cart or like a backpack or yeah
something like that and you couldn't
really you couldn't buy any [ __ ] ice
cream or nothing like that right side
tracking like a [ __ ] what else
is already what else is okay people are
in people are in here what else is new
yeah I mean well the whole the whole
reason we got started talking about that
was because we were talking about the
holy water and then and then I got off
into communion Wafers and then we
started talking about food again yeah
because I was like why didn't they make
them good somebody mentioned sidecars
side cars are extremely unstable and
they they ruin a motorcycles handling
they're very outdated it's better to
Trail something behind you if you got to
have it it's got to be on a Dem
Universal kind of like a U-joint swivel
and two wheels they have gold wings that
carry them around in the back but you
could hook something like that up on a
sport bike if you wanted to
the cruiser
but that's the thing that's I think
that's one that actually that's the best
scene in this episode is that scene
where she's driving that kid around and
like [ __ ] just she's not even like
looking at the root and she's just like
staring at him the whole time I have to
say like the actress in this I don't
know if she was in any other um I
thought she was in some other episodes
but man she crushed it in this one she
really like committed to the whole uh
possession thing and uh she was super
super creepy in that [ __ ] scene where
she was like driving the kid around
she's in a bunch of them she just she
always plays like the mom type of Deal
or the realtor or you know she plays a
bunch of different roles she's good I'm
gonna have to look her up like that
because especially like in the in the
kind of like final scene of this where
they're doing the exorcism I was like
wow she really uh she leaned into that
man she was like yep I'm [ __ ]
possessed she's kind of sexy too
something about her she's kind of sick
she's kind of creepy sexy they're creepy
sexy yeah crazy yeah she's crazy
she's probably in her 40s and then when
she was doing this so she's I imagine
probably pushing 60 now yeah because I
think that this episode well geez this
was season three episode eight so what
was season three 2006 2007 something
like that yeah so yeah so she's probably
like way older right now it's funny it's
funny how like time flies how time flies
look at how old these are because it's
like we watch them all the time so it
just seems like they don't seem that
they don't seem that old yeah you look
at the cars and you're like no these are
pretty old yeah I was like oh look
that's like my old ass car yeah but you
know what are you gonna do my poor
little car at least it's still running I
don't like to say anything about it
because because I'll jinx it you know
what I mean now I did have like the kind
of side panel on the passenger side door
like keeps falling off yeah I had to
glue that back in positions I don't know
it doesn't do anything so I just kind of
threw it it's a back seat it's a trim
piece right I'm gonna put that [ __ ] in
there man it looks tacky I just gotta I
just the heat got to the heat gets to
everything here over time and the heat
destroyed the glue yeah everything just
keeps like cracking off and it just the
if that car was red it would be long
destroyed now the red never survives
Florida well that's why a lot of people
just buy white ones yeah it just becomes
pink and then it becomes then then the
paint just
birds off of it yeah down to the bare
metal
Danny rolling said uh she became a Karen
to the boyfriend which she was going to
blame him for her injuries now see I was
trying to remember because I watched
this last night and then I watched it
again like real quick like this morning
when I was doing the notes but I was
just kind of like I think after that
point like we don't see that guy anymore
like he was just like [ __ ] that I'm out
I don't care if you're possessed or not
or did he come back later I didn't think
I don't think he did to be honest I was
I was pretty loaded when I was watching
this movie no [ __ ] yeah this episode I'd
seen it several times many times
actually
well maybe you'll remember good like
yeah and you dozed off again yeah at the
very end that's what it does I think
that happened like the last time we were
watching a movie he's like well you
can't tell because he's like sitting
like kind of on his side like that and
he had his hand like up like that yeah
and then like I was making a joke or
something like he didn't laugh or like
react and I was like okay and then like
I looked like that and he was sleeping
and then like it was at the Oasis I got
I got pretty trashed yeah yeah and then
like after that yeah because that well
you know then like after that like the
the credits rolled and I got up to go to
the bathroom and I came back and he was
still there going yes like that just
like still kind of sitting up and I was
just like uh okay I was like and then he
woke up and I was like well do you want
to watch Dracula because that's what
we're gonna talk about tomorrow no too
tired and it was like what was it was
like quarter to nine yeah and then you
just fell asleep women the other when
the man cave and fell asleep and woke up
at two o'clock in the morning fell
asleep in the back yeah I watched I
watched a whole other movie yeah that I
was gonna review and then I think I
heard you turn turn the TV off and I
came in bed
I don't remember what time you did
because I remember I I got him I got him
been there I think you were still awake
no I don't think so because I don't
remember you coming in there yeah
and then I woke up at like quarter to
four because I had to go to the bathroom
again and then I couldn't go back to
sleep so I laid there for hours and
hours then I think I fell asleep for
like half an hour but then I woke up at
like seven yeah so you know so I'm a
little bit tired that but you know what
else is now I'm kind of like used to it
at this point
uh but yeah all right so let's get into
talking about the possessed season three
episode eight of a haunting so uh so
this all of this situation supposedly
took place in the fall of 2000. now
again this one had uh the woman that was
at the center of it is you know in
Shadow so she's not using her real name
uh so you know John's office is on there
he's using his real name obviously
there's like a priest on there who did
the exorcism on her he was using his
real name presumably
um but the other people not so much so
there wasn't like a lot of supplemental
material about this one
so the name that they gave her was
um Mary volkmann and she is a paranormal
investigator
now at the very beginning of the story
uh she gets called out they don't go a
huge amount into like all the details
about this but she um gets called out to
this farmhouse in Virginia somewhere
and apparently what happened with that
was there was like a contractor who was
out at this Farmhouse like the barn
specifically I think and he was like
renovating it and I guess like all kind
of paranormal Shenanigans were going on
in there and he couldn't like actually
they got so bad that he couldn't like
finish the job she said the real woman
said on there that at one point the
circular saw
um had gone on even though it wasn't
plugged in
so you know obviously you're going to
have a hard time like doing [ __ ] with uh
stuff like that going on
so you know they get called out her and
her team get called out to This Barn to
like investigate whatever the hell was
going on here so she comes out with um
she has this other like assistant or
this other woman that's like on the team
who's you know they're calling her Jane
Reeves but I'm assuming that's not her
real name uh but yeah so they're kind of
like she's kind of like a new you know
Paranormal Investigator so they're
coming there together and I think there
was somebody else there like on the team
as well so they go into the barn to
check it out and I guess because Mary is
kind of like the senior member of the
team she said well I'm just going to go
in by myself you know because I don't
know like you know not only just because
there's paranormal [ __ ] might be
happening but also because it just might
be dangerous because it's still like
under construction or whatnot so she
goes in there
and she has like a little uh micro
cassette recorder thing and they're
trying to get like some EVPs and [ __ ]
now while she's up in the Loft uh she's
kind of like moving some straw around
and [ __ ] like that and she sees some
candle wax and guess what good old
pentagram so here the satanists have
been in here satanists they've been in
here everywhere I kind of feel like this
that happens on a lot of these episodes
where they move into a house or they
move somewhere and they're like look
Satan this have been here they draw
[ __ ] yeah so they've been doing all
this black magic I really don't feel
like there's that many people doing
black magic no I mean teenagers will go
and do like you know they'll draw like
some [ __ ] pentagrams on [ __ ] just to
be that way but I don't think they're
actually in there doing [ __ ] rituals
or nothing
but uh but yeah so she finds uh the
pentagram and the candle wax here you
know the Goths have been here obviously
they're to blame for everything
and as soon as she finds that she said
that she felt a stabbing pain in her
stomach and felt violently ill and
basically what happens is there's kind
of like
like there's kind of like a jump scare
where a skull of some kind it looked
like a bull or something
um it's on a rope and it kind of comes
like swinging down like into the Loft
and like scares the [ __ ] out of her and
you know it was it was very like a
Leatherface kind of Moment Like a Texas
Chainsaw Massacre kind of moment where
this skull just came flying at her and I
guess they were trying to like imply
that it was ooh that's like the [ __ ]
I don't know it was just like a skull on
a rope basically but um she yeah so she
basically says she got really really
sick and she's like
um you know at this point I felt like
there was really something in there that
didn't want us in there and she got like
really really scared and was basically
telling everybody to get the [ __ ] out of
here because you know there's something
really bad in here and they don't want
to see her and I don't want you guys in
here because it's not safe or whatever
so later on that night she's back home
now she has a 13 year old son named Josh
who is not real
um jazzed about this whole paranormal
research thing that she's doing I don't
know if it's just because he thinks it's
stupid or if he thinks that it's
dangerous you know what I mean because
some of the stuff that he says later on
I don't know I I kind of feel like maybe
he just like is not real comfortable
with it or it scares him or something
like that I mean he's only 13.
so um she also has a boyfriend named
Mike and I guess they've been dating for
you know several years at this point and
like I said they're engaged and uh Mike
is not real he's very very skeptical of
the supernatural so he's kind of like
you know he knows what she does but he's
just kind of like whatever I don't
really like believe in any of that kind
of stuff now she has like a day job this
isn't her full job like Paranormal
Investigator she's um a physical
therapist so she has her own private
practice so that's what she does for her
day job but she just does this
paranormal thing like on the side
so a few days after this
she's listening to the tapes that she
made like when she was in the barn and
like all in the scary skull thing
happened
and Jane is there too
and on the tape they hear you know good
old demonic sounding voice that says
your God can't help you now so yeah and
they're like holy [ __ ] did you hear that
yeah I heard that
so she says that that was the first time
anything like that had ever happened to
her like on any other investigation and
it scared the [ __ ] out of her and she
said it was very very clearly not a
human voice uh and it sounded like Super
Evil
so at this point Mary calls up her
Mentor who's John zappis if you don't
know who John's office is he's been on a
bunch of Haunting episodes he is the
Warrens nephew and I could be wrong
about this but I thought that he
inherited the the Museum of scary
paranormal [ __ ] that they Master heard I
thought I don't know about nowadays
because like I said this was a while
back and I don't know how old he is now
I think he's still alive but I think
that he's the one that runs the museum
if indeed that's still even around I
haven't really checked I have to admit
but he's on like a lot of these so yeah
so he's related to the Warrens
uh so as you and like the warranty is
based in Connecticut
so she asks them about this weird EVP
that they got
um you know which you know that's not
good a demonic voice saying your God
can't help you now I mean you know
that's that's probably not a good thing
so John says well when you're like a
sensitive individual that's what he
called her so I'm assuming he met
someone with like psychic powers or
whatever uh so apparently like if you're
dealing with them some satanic [ __ ] like
you know people that have been in there
doing satanic [ __ ] and Conjuring up God
knows what uh that this is going to be
like a really dangerous situation so he
says to Mary I because she's a Catholic
um you know I recommend that you you
know have to protect yourself in case
something gravitated toward you so it's
like go to mass go to confession do all
that you know all the Catholic stuff and
he also said I think that maybe you
should not investigate this case anymore
um you should probably drop it because I
think it's going to be too dangerous for
you and like your other investigators
might get caught in the crossfire and
[ __ ] like that
um you know
so she was like well I guess she didn't
really want to drop it because she had
kind of like told them that she was
going to go through with it so I guess
she did it
uh but she did kind of take some
precautions like later on that night to
protect her house and her family uh she
hung crucifixes in all the rooms and she
has those blessed Saint medallions you
know what I mean that like a lot of
Catholics have I guess
um so basically she thinks that you know
God's Gonna protect her with those now
she has a sister named Allison uh also
not her real name who is attending grad
school in California and she's going to
be like a psychotherapist I guess so the
two of them like talk on the phone all
the time even though they live like
across the country
and so Mary tells her sister that she's
worried about this Barn case that she's
been working on because of the
pentagrams and the satanic whatnot
um Allison said that she found this very
unusual like I guess that Mary had
worked on a lot of cases before and like
nothing had really like bothered her or
scared her so the fact that she was so
was freaking out about this one like you
know she thought that was a little bit
alarming so she asked her if she's
talked to John about it
um and she's like yeah and he told me
what to do and blah blah and then you
know sister she's not there so she can't
really do much of anything and she says
okay well I'll just put you on my prayer
list because I guess she's got one of
those
so um so that's basically all she could
do
so they're like okay now everything was
fine for about six months and for a
while they started thinking that this
whole demonic voice on the EVP was maybe
just like a fluke or you know maybe it
was just who knows
so they had kind of I don't think they
forgot about it but they just weren't
really thinking about it anymore but
then uh something kind of bad happens
like in the family
so Mary's mom had surgery like uh to for
like a knee replacement I think and the
surgery went bad like she got a staph
infection
which happens sometimes and uh the
infection got really bad and the doctors
were not actually sure if she was gonna
pull through or not
so Mary is you know not getting a lot of
sleep she's very very stressed out
because she thinks her mom might die so
she suspects that because she was going
through so much [ __ ] like in her family
life that she wasn't on guard the way
she normally would be like guarding
against demonic incursion if you want to
call it that you know because you got to
keep ever Vigilant to keep the demons
from
inserting themselves into your various
holes yeah well you're not looking she
comes up with a screen
that's funny well they gotta get in
somehow
they come in through your skin just
right into your mind yeah you think okay
they don't have to like come in your
butthole or nothing no they're they're
in another dimension
it's Quantum I think it's more fun I
think it's more fun if they have to look
in your butthole yeah you see how Jenny
does not believe in possession
no I don't but you know
I think it's unlikely
it is yeah yeah it is yeah
um so yeah so she thinks maybe she
suspects that maybe this is when The
Possession occurred because she wasn't
like on the lookout for it right
so a few fights after this like after
she you know had been in the hospital
like visiting her mom or whatever
uh Mary's like in her house at night and
she's you know just working and [ __ ]
like do answering emails and blah blah
she's like hey you know I had a medical
emergency I can't like come investigate
your ghost right now I'll I'll get back
with you later on let me qualifies
something I said I said I think
possession is unlikely
the reason why I say that is because the
most credible cases
that I've heard of or read involving
possession can be interpreted also as
Poltergeist phenomenon I believe the I I
believe the concept of demonic
possession is a misinterpretation of
poltergeist phenomena which does exist
I've seen that
but it had that happened and what
happened to me in in my family and that
happened in the Middle Ages actually not
even the Middle Ages back in the 70s and
60s and you had the Warrens there they
would have interpreted that as
demonic possession well they did they
interpreted everything is demonic
possession right like you didn't have to
call them
even in the middle there was everything
everything was demonic possession but
they would have said this is a demon and
it's possessed to this kid
Poltergeist phenomena it's a very
Western thing to project into that and
go yeah that's demonic possession
there are old cases that happened in the
Far East you know like Japan where
um investigators Samurai you know
intellectual Samurai had seen it and
said no this is an imbalance of chi
coming out of this girl they didn't
interpret it as Poltergeist or excuse me
as demonic
it's it's Chi it's psychic yeah they saw
it as something different which is
probably a lot more closer to what it
might actually be yeah then because I
don't know the Japanese that was like
1700s I think with the case there the
Japanese uh we're a lot closer to
what I believe for you know based on my
experience could be correct there's a
psychic temper tantrum
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
and the thing too about demonic
possession is that
I kind of feel like it it particularly
um arises when people have been raised
in a very religious
background and they're just acting out
in a way that they're almost like
they're it's like a suggestion or the
way that they're expecting to act and
then it's kind of like a feedback loop
because then like you know and they
believe it then they believe it and now
it's just kind of like yeah so you can
like talk yourself into acting like that
yeah too so yeah
you know I'm [ __ ] for you Star Wars
fans what you're talking about is
[ __ ] the Sith and the Jedi is what
you're talking about
the force
which that was all borrowed from Chinese
Chinese philosophers [ __ ] yin and
yang Yin force and yang Force which uh
probably true yeah
well they went crazy they went sideways
with that [ __ ] too
where you can
I don't want to get into it go ahead
well you can run across the top of trees
and Float [ __ ] run and do do things
that ninja do run across the top of the
surface of water and you let me do
you're not gonna be able to do that
it's like Scientology saying yeah you
can take something that's true and then
go too far with it you know yeah going
crazy with anything yeah so yeah so
she's in her house uh just doing regular
[ __ ] and then suddenly she hears this
really creepy sound and this was
actually a good
um sound design on this one because I
actually even said because he was still
awake at this point and when she hears
the noise I was like ooh that's a creepy
ass noise like um she thought it was the
cat and like I can understand that
because Pookie makes some weird ass
noises sometimes and like I'll be at the
desk and I can't see her but all of a
sudden I hear her like making some like
bizarre ass trilling noise like from the
other room and I'm like what the [ __ ]
was that I mean I know it's probably her
but the the noise that she hears she
thinks it's a cat but it kind of sounded
like she said it was grunting like a pig
so it kind of sounded like Pig grunting
but not quite it was much creepier than
that I mean that would be creepy enough
if you were in the house by yourself and
heard a pig grunting inexplicably but um
but yeah so it was like a creepy sound I
wanted to say something about that too
because this
I don't know if it was just my
imagination because remember I think I
said I mentioned this to you but the
score in this one was a lot different
than normal you know what I mean I kind
of feel like the score it did but like a
lot of the scores in this and this
wasn't like a later one this was like a
season three I kind of feel like the
scores and most of them were a lot more
low-key whereas this one was like more
dramatic like it seemed to kind of like
stand out a little bit more I think they
were trying to so much say that I
noticed it it was not a ghost story so
they were trying something new if you
asked me they were trying to go maybe
that's what it was more like Exorcist
type stuff maybe that's what it was yeah
really this one isn't this one isn't
quite as exciting if you ask me than
some of the ghost stuff so they're
trying to make it more exciting using
using audio yeah maybe that's what it is
yeah because this has a lot more
um audio cues like you said than like a
lot more dramatic kind of musical stings
and things like that which they don't
usually because usually the music in
these is pretty like low-key like pretty
understated yeah because visually not a
lot happens uh in terms of special
effects in this one
yeah because a lot of it's like internal
it's because she's like possessed right
so she doesn't really see much of
anything like she doesn't see like
apparitions or like [ __ ] flying yeah
it's one of the reasons why I think we
chose against doing this earlier maybe
because they're like well this one's
kind of not a lot happens in the
physical world right that one scene of
her driving that was pretty good that
was the best part honestly but I will
say though that even though I generally
prefer like the more ghosty type stories
and the more Poltergeist type stories
than the possessiony type stories I will
say that this one did have like two of
the creepiest one like the pig grunting
sound which I was like ooh that's really
creepy like that noise that that they
had going and the scene of her driving I
was like it's that those are two of the
creepiest like scenes in all of the
haunting episodes that I remember so you
know good good one there
but yeah so she hears like something
grunting like a pig which like I said
that that usually denotes something uh
demonic right there so basically she's
like well I guess the sun was still in
the house at this point but she was like
well I didn't really want to tell them
what was going on like I want him to be
safe but I didn't want him to be scared
because if he was scared then maybe like
the demon would like glom onto him as
well
so Mary's mom uh you know happily like
gets better from her infection but she's
still in the hospital and Mary's
visiting her and mom basically says you
know you look like [ __ ] I mean she
doesn't say that but well she says you
look terrible
I think she says and she's like gee
thanks Mom I'm like yeah that's such a
mom thing to say but uh my mom wouldn't
say anything like that but a lot of moms
do
um yeah Mary says well I haven't really
been getting much sleep and she said
that she had a lot of what she called
nightmares while she was awake like
during the day
and in this case this was also like a
pretty good like creepy scene so she's
standing there by the bed uh her mom's
bed and then there was another
patient like in the other bed and a
nurse comes in and is like tending to
the other patient and Mary like looks
over there and she thinks that she sees
the nurse over there like pulling like
all the the entrails or internal organs
like I'm like kind of like going hey
like would be all these bloody like
livers and [ __ ] like in her hands and
then she's staring at the nurse like
what the [ __ ] why are you pulling all
you know what I mean so that was like a
pretty good scene too and then the nurse
is like what the [ __ ] are you looking at
lady like you know what I mean and she's
like uh no I'm fine I'm fine but yeah
she said I don't know if she saw that
like really because she didn't say that
but that's what they showed like in the
reenactment that she saw so I thought
that was pretty cool but yeah she's
seeing that kind of crap like during the
day pulling guts out and then
um they kind of show her she's at work
like I said she's a physical therapist
so she's in there like you know
manipulating This Woman's like tennis
arm you know like pushing it over there
and all that other kind of stuff and
then the woman like suddenly turns to
her and like talks all demony at her
like you know your God can't help you or
whatever like the demon said to her but
then like totally acts like nothing
happened and then you know so Mary's
like what the [ __ ] did you just say and
she's like what I didn't say anything
and then she's like oh is our session's
over and she's like wait is it like she
lost some time or some [ __ ] so
apparently she was having all that kind
of stuff going on
so
um she's basically like okay well she
didn't really tell her son obviously or
I guess her boyfriend like what was
going on because she didn't really think
that they could help her
and it did occur to her that maybe she
had some kind of like mental illness
like maybe she was developing
schizophrenia or something like that
which is something that you have to
consider if you're like seeing weird
[ __ ] like that
um you know or that she was just like
super stressed out and you know she was
just having hallucinations so she's
basically well in a way she said she was
kind of hoping that it was like a mental
health issue because then at least she
could get medication and it would like
solve the problem so she calls up her
sister Allison who like I said was
studying to be a psychotherapist and
she's asking her she's like do you think
I'm schizophrenic like she's telling her
like all the stuff that's going on and
apparently her sister is like um no that
doesn't sound anything like uh you know
what the sister said she said she didn't
have any of the classic indicators for
psychosis no Mania no evidence of
schizophrenia none of the typical signs
that you find for diagnosis that's what
she said so she's like yeah I don't
think it's a mental illness I think
maybe you have like some other uh issues
some other problems that you're having
so and like I said Allison was a
Catholic too and like you know was uh
had a lot of like strong religious Faith
so basically she's like uh yeah I think
maybe like there's some demonic [ __ ]
going on so probably you should call
somebody and get your house blessed like
ASAP I think I like I have a hair in my
mouth and I can't get it out okay there
uh so Mary like basically calls up the
parish priest has him come over and like
bless the house and uh the mom who's now
out of the hospital she's fine uh she
comes over and does the whole blessing
and Jane comes over uh the priest also
blesses all their medallions which is he
just blesses the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
everything like with his little dude
sensor thing whatever that is
um but not too long after that just as
in many of these episodes the second you
bring the church in and they bless your
[ __ ] stuff gets like exponentially worse
and that is exactly what happened here
she has the guy come in everything's
blessed everything's fine but then
Mary's in bed one night and they show
her like laying there and then there's
like this Shadow like kind of passes
over her
and then like an invisible force
basically starts throwing her ass around
like all over the rim like pulling her
off the bed like chucking not really
like chucking her against the wall but
pretty much like pulling her off the bed
and she's trying to stay on the bed and
it's like this big thing
um but basically she said something I
couldn't see attack me that's what she
said
um so basically she's like
she's like she kind of ran outside the
house but then she's like well I don't
this isn't going to do any good because
I know the house isn't haunted like this
is me like it's attached to me so even
if I go somewhere else in the same [ __ ]
is gonna happen so she felt like really
bad because there was nothing she could
do about it
so she calls her sister back and is
basically like okay well I'm starting to
freak out um because I'm this [ __ ] is
like throwing me all over the my bedroom
and I'm not here for it so Allison this
okay this was another thing that I
thought was weird Alison says why don't
you call zaphus they always call him by
his last name which I thought was kind
of funny I guess because it's more
distinctive than John
um but Mary is like she doesn't want to
for some reason and I'm not really sure
why she basically says well I'm not
comfortable calling him and I'm afraid
of what he might do I'm like what do you
mean like he might do an exorcism and
you'll be fine is that like what else is
he gonna do like that's bad I don't
really understand and she didn't have a
problem calling him before so I don't
really know I don't know if this was
just like some kind of manufactured
conflict they wanted to put in here or
if it was like the demon like telling
her it's like oh I can't call him or
because I don't know I I didn't really
get it like why she didn't want to call
him because she called him before I
don't know I don't get it
um and Allison even says well calling
him she said would have probably been
the smartest thing that she could have
done because he would have actually set
some things in a motion to try and help
her which like I said exactly so I don't
really understand like why she was
afraid to call him because she seemed
like Lucid most of the time like when
she wasn't like all demonie and stuff so
I don't know I didn't get it
um so basically she's talking to her
sister on the phone still and then she
gets all demoney like once she's on the
phone and basically starts going like
your faith is nothing like you doing
that kind of stuff
um and then Allison's like yeah okay
that's like immediately that's not my
sister yeah she's demonically possessed
and uh you know and so she's saying that
she feels completely helpless like
something's taking over her body yada
yada
so um she decides even though that whole
priest blessing thing earlier didn't
work out so good like everything got
worse she decides she's gonna like
double down on this [ __ ] so they show
her and she's in her room and she's
reading the Bible and all this other
stuff and then she said like the
medallions that she had you know what I
mean the the priest had blessed before
she said that they start she keeps like
pulling him away from her chest like she
said they started like burning and
itching and she felt like they were
strangling like she couldn't breathe
um and then so she ends up like chucking
the medallions across the room also and
I noticed this too she Chucks the Bible
across the room too but they only showed
that in Shadow and I said I wonder if
they didn't show her like actually
throwing the Bible across the room
because people would get offended yeah
well I think the first few seasons I
think it was kind of a religious
um company that made these I think they
were Christian so that might be
didn't we didn't we get down to
believing that I mean that's what I
thought I think it was that's what I
thought but it's a good product you know
what I mean I think out of out of the
Christian products this series is you
know if they were Christian I'm pretty
sure they were out of Christian products
this series the first couple seasons
were some of the best things they ever
made yeah yeah but I was under the
impression that like the the religious
company took over later but I could be
wrong about that all right because it's
kind of seemed like the first seasons
were kind of like a mixed bag like some
of them were like super religiously and
then the other ones not so much maybe so
I don't really know I'm just saying that
they were probably just hedging their
bets because it's like well they wanted
a show like she's evil and like
possessed and everything so it's like
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] you know [ __ ] that
Bible and she just like throws it across
the room but they're like well we can't
actually we don't want to actually like
have her throw an actual Bible because
maybe people on the crew would get
offended or like people so I wonder if
they gave it like changed out the book
like they gave her another book
it's like here here's a copy of Twilight
check that across the room you know what
I mean no one would be offended in that
that's what I don't know this is the
kind of [ __ ] that I think about when I'm
watching this show
I know but see I know but I picked it up
on it though but that's because that's
how my brain works that's how my brain
works I notice like weird little [ __ ]
like that you know what I mean it was
just something that I noticed
um so basically yeah uh so she says at
this point she's like every time I tried
to do anything like to make all of this
better um I would get attacked and she
said she kind of started to lose her
faith or she started to get kind of like
mad at God because he was like falling
out of the job like not really helping
her out um you know so there was that so
finally she calls zappis like I don't
know why she didn't do it before but she
does and she I kind of laughed at this
point like I said I props to the actress
in this because she actually did a great
job I really like her and she really
like committed to it which I thought was
cool she did not phone this in like not
not not by any stretch of the
imagination so she's basically crying on
the phone like with zaphus and saying
that she thinks she has an attachment
it's attachment
um you know it's a demon it's like
stuck on you like a remora on a shark
that's that's what I pictured anyway now
during the call though
she starts growling and then she's
basically like we don't need any help
like all that kind of stuff and John's
like oh yeah that's definitely a demon
and shit's getting serious so you know
we better like intervene
so
the thing that happens like she's all
beat to [ __ ] I guess because of the
stuff that happened before like with a
demon like tossing her around the room
because she's got like a [ __ ] black
eye she looks she looks like hell
so she goes she drives over to Jane's
house
and she tells Jane I've been attacked
which is obvious because her face is all
[ __ ] bruised and [ __ ]
Jane says oh my God like did you call
the police Mary said um no I wasn't
attacked by a person hey you remember
that Barn case we did we had that really
creepy EVP yeah I think that demon has
like [ __ ] latched on to me and is
beating my ass so you know and then
while that's happening I think Danny
Rowland brought this up earlier then
while that's happening she has I guess
it was like a vision where she growls at
Jane about not needing help and then she
threatens her with like a rake or some
[ __ ] like there was a rake or a shovel
or something like in the front yard and
she like picks it up and then she starts
like coming at her like that like
because yeah Danny rolling would say it
was like American Gladiators I thought
of that scene if you've seen like um
Mystery Science Theater and you've seen
that terrible terrible 80s movie
hobgoblins and there's like a very long
extended sequence in there in which two
guys fight each other in the front yard
of a tract house with Garden implements
uh it kind of reminded me of that like
big time uh if you if you know you know
you if you've seen it you know what I'm
talking about so yeah she's like
basically like well I'm gonna get you
this [ __ ] rake or shovel or whatever
the [ __ ] it is and there's that but then
like Jane's little boy like peeks around
the door like Mommy what the [ __ ]
going on out there and then they're like
oops like that didn't really happen like
she was just imagining it so I guess the
demon was making her see like this is
what you'll do if you stay here you know
what I mean so she kind of like snaps
out of it and then she's like okay well
I have to leave because if I don't you
know I'm gonna hurt you guys and I don't
really watch the shoes it's just like
bye and then she like goes and gets in
her car and like drives back home
so Jane at this point and they don't
really go a lot into this but Jane at
this point she starts wearing like her
medals and all that and then she goes
back in her house like after this
incident and then her little boy like
toddles into the living room and says
mommy there's a man in the other room
and then she's like what the [ __ ] and
then like so
so she goes like with the thing like the
cross and she's praying and [ __ ] like
that like looking around in the closet
and everything like that I think she saw
like a shadow at least in the
reenactment but she doesn't find
anything like she goes in the closet
there's nothing in there but they don't
really go into
that anymore like they don't really say
that Jane like saw any [ __ ] at her house
like other than that one thing so I
thought that was kind of like a little
bit of a loose end there
um so later on Mary comes home late and
Mike her boyfriend is wondering where
she's been it's like oh my God I was
worried sick blah blah I thought you
were in a car accident and then at that
point like Mary or at least the demon
like you know sitting on her basically
like runs Mike off like she she's like
just get out of our Lives pow and then
she like [ __ ] she just [ __ ] smacks
him right across the face like that
you're saying I don't love you Mike and
blah blah and then she says if you don't
leave I'm gonna call the cops and tell
them you did this to my face because
like I said the demon like [ __ ] up her
face right like beat her up remember
what she did there yeah and I was like
oh
and then she said later and I don't
think you see the boyfriend after this
please correct I'm out of here yeah he's
like I don't want to deal with this
demon possession thing you're gonna set
me up for all kinds of [ __ ] you can have
DNA to prove it
that's what I mean I was just kind of
like he was just like okay I'm washing
my hands well I I I don't either
honestly I don't gotta protect himself I
don't
she hit you with a rate charge
well the thing about it's not even just
that it's just like if if she thinks
she's possessed by a demon whether she
really was or not it's just like I'd be
like yeah I don't think I need to like
[ __ ] watch Pokemon she's laying on
her back went right and then rolled over
and looked at me
it's so weird maybe Pookie is possessed
by a demon it's obsessed by a demon yeah
that's what she'll sit on the edge of
the bed like sometimes and like watch a
haunting with us and I'll be like demons
Pokey yeah and then her little ears just
go like that that's like
she doesn't know what demons are she
knows what screaming is yeah she doesn't
like screaming because like you know and
you know we watch a lot of horror movies
so you know obviously there's a lot of
screaming going on so but she doesn't
like it she gets like really nervous
she's like screaming it's just like
machines beeping and yeah yeah [ __ ] that
freaks her out yeah cause like sometimes
well the funny thing too if you put
something in the microwave downstairs
and you forget about it like we have a
microwave that just keeps beeping until
you go down there and every few seconds
ago yeah and it'll be it's really
annoying
um but Pookie will run up the stairs and
be like
she's smart she knows she knows what the
words Mouse and mice are if I'm talking
about the toys
if I said get your mouse and she'll look
right at him they're right there yeah
she's like yeah my mom she knows all
kinds of different words she knows what
we're saying yeah it's funny she totally
does yeah she totally does yeah so uh so
basically she says
um this is a quote from the show she
says things come out of your mouth that
you don't want to say
um it's as if you're a hostage in your
own body and something else is taking
control
like you're like you're a mech suit like
there's like a little thing inside the
mech suit that's what it's like that's
exactly what these entities wanted
wanted me alone with no help so that's
basically she I guess she's saying that
the demon was trying to like drive
everyone away so that she wouldn't have
any support system so I guess that's
what it is because when she told Mike
like I don't love you like get out of
here she didn't sound demony she sounded
like her regular voice but like pissed
off you know what I mean because I think
when she was on the phone with the other
people she would usually sound like
demony like it was still her voice
obviously but she was like like that you
know what I mean but this time she just
likes kind of said it normal
but yeah that was pretty [ __ ] up when
she was I'll tell her I'll tell the cops
you did this and I'm like harsh babe but
yeah he was just like yeah bye and he
just like took off
and at this point like I guess she hears
her son Josh I guess this was the same
night and he's like crying in his room
and he said that he had heard something
and I thought this was very specific he
said he sounded he heard something that
sounded like two wolves growling I'm
like how did you know it was two wolves
could have just been one or three how do
you know what two wolves growling sounds
I was like that's very specific I just I
don't know why again I don't know why I
fixated on that little detail I don't
know why I don't know why I fixate on
those kind of things
um but yeah so he's crying and she's
like what's your problem he's like yeah
I heard growling and that's not good but
then he says
um I don't actually believe in prayer
anymore because I kept praying that you
would knock it off with the Paranormal
investigations and you didn't like so my
prayer didn't work so [ __ ] that and then
he also says he doesn't believe in God
anymore and then she's very very
offended by that
although she does admit you know I still
believe in God but I was just very very
angry and I guess my anger like made it
easy for the demon to like take over and
she ends up like throwing away her
medallions even her she's like not
throwing him she just kind of puts him
in the little wicker trash Basket in her
bedroom like you can just go back there
and get him it's not you know
um so she kind of like tries to maintain
you know so that Josh doesn't get more
freaked out than normal now I guess like
Allison who lived in California like I
said she was coming to visit like for
the Fourth of July weekend or whatever
and I guess she was staying with their
mom who only lived like a few miles away
from where Mary and her son lived so
this was the part like I said this was
my favorite scene in the whole thing so
Mary drives her son Josh to her mom's
house which is only like a few miles
away but the whole time she took she
drives like a total bat out of hell like
she doesn't like stop for any she's
driving on the wrong [ __ ] side she's
up on the [ __ ] sidewalk she's running
red lights and stop signs and she's just
like all over and she's the whole time
she's just staring at her son in the
passenger seat and like driving and that
kid is absolutely losing his [ __ ]
[ __ ] as you would like if that was your
[ __ ] mom but just the face that she's
making
and they keep like cutting back to her
face and like the cars like driving
everywhere and Hawking and [ __ ] like
that it was just like a great scene and
she looked so [ __ ] creepy
um yeah when the kid was just obviously
like terrified so basically yeah she
stares at him creepily the whole time
not once looking at the road now Mary
once they get to the house like the kid
like jumps the [ __ ] out of the car and
like runs in the house she's crazy she's
crazy you know what I mean but Mary said
she had absolutely no memory of at all
like of the whole drive over there and
she said you know Josh told me later
that I stared at him the whole entire
time and he doesn't know how we got
there without having an accident so yeah
but that was like a great scene I
thought that was one of the best and it
was like daytime and everything but it's
just like I guess it was her face you
know what I mean like she looked she
like I said she really committed to the
creepiness so you know it was like
really good
so Mary then stumbles into the house
again looking like complete [ __ ] as you
know just give her a break she's
demonically possessed uh and she that's
just my phone it's my phone ringing my
phone ringing
um so she comes in the house and again
you know where's mom's holy water which
again I thought was very funny oh it's
just right there like in the kitchen
like a bottle of holy water so she tries
to drink it but I guess she can't like
she starts choking and stuff and then
she goes demony again and says I don't
need your help blah blah and then she
says
um stuff like her sister like goes out
and tries to talk to her and then she
has a rake again for some reason I don't
know maybe the demon that's possessing
her like really likes rakes that's like
his thing but um she's kind of saying
stuff like why do you care about that
mother of yours why do you even believe
in God what's he ever done for you blah
blah blah and you know the sister is
just kind of like whoa okay this is this
is not good so at this point um the
sister goes to make iced tea with again
with some stealth holy water in there
um but then she comes out with the
glasses she puts holy water in
everybody's which I don't know why I
don't know I just thought that was
really funny she was holy water in
everybody's teeth let me get you some
more ice yeah oh my eyes melted
but then she comes out like with two
glasses like hey or we're gonna drink it
there's totally not holy water in here
so you're not it burns it burns but you
know so she comes out with the glasses
uh but Mary's already taken off and then
like in the background you can hear her
car going you know what I mean so she's
like driving like a crazy person again I
guess like the demon is keeping her from
getting into accident so there's that I
mean the Demon's like making her drive
really crazy
so at this point Alice and the sister
calls zappis and says um yeah shit's
getting really bad with Mary uh we
really need to like move on this we need
to do something about this because it's
getting out of control
uh so Zappa says well keep Josh the sun
there at the mom's house and I'm gonna
call some people and they're gonna call
some people and we're gonna like arrange
an exorcist
and that's how he said it on the show
too like there was well well he there
was a dramatic pause and I think you had
fallen asleep at this point but I was
just like you know and he's going to
arrange for
an exorcism
and I just like laughed I was like ooh
dramatic pause I really like that I love
the [ __ ] I mean Anthony call is like
yeah he's like [ __ ] iconic he's
iconic but it's just kind of like it's
funny because nowadays I mean every
there's been like 40 bajillion like
exorcism movies it's like oh exorcism
yawn you know what I mean but it's just
like so it was funny to me that they
were trying to like do this big dramatic
in case you've never heard of it before
right and exorcism you know what I mean
well at least they didn't like explain
what an exorcism was because that
happened like on some of the older shows
yeah they're explaining what it actually
they always well and like I said
nowadays and I think even on this one
when they say EVP like they always say
electronic voicemail but like they
explain what it is I'm like every
[ __ ] knows what that is now
because of the proliferation of
paranormal TV shows yeah if they're
watching that program they know it's an
EVP yeah and I'm like duh everybody
knows what a damn maybe because even I
know what it is everybody knows what an
EVP is but I just think it's funny that
they have to like explain but like I
said at least they didn't explain well
an exorcism is a thing where you just
like read the Bible at people and try to
like expel the demon from their body so
there's that
um so so Zappa says
um you know we didn't necessarily know
he's like we were kind of like you know
we thought this is going to be dangerous
we didn't know uh what kind of demon we
were dealing with we didn't know if she
was going to become violent uh we didn't
know if like something bad was gonna
happen to her son so they had to like do
something like as soon as possible to
kind of get him get her away from like
the sun to so she wouldn't hurt him or
nothing so Mary like you know for her
kids she said okay I'm gonna go ahead
with the exorcism and um I had to do a
dramatic pause to you uh you know
because they didn't want [ __ ] to
escalate and you know something bad
happening or something like I said
so Allison and Jane Drive Mary to
Connecticut because that's where his
office lives for the exorcism now
Mary it's funny because the the narrator
like Anthony Cauley says Mary knows that
at best the exorcism will be extremely
painful at worst it could be fatal which
okay I don't know about painful though
is it I don't know I've never been
exercising God during them well I know
that but I don't think that was so much
like yeah I guess so we got them tied up
they're not [ __ ] let them drink
sometimes you know because they have it
dudes that don't know what they're doing
you know they're fighting
fighting the uh the possessed
you gotta tied down
that was one thing though in this one is
that like they do the exercise they
didn't Tire down though they just kind
of had everybody like holding on to her
I'm like are you sure that that's the
best idea I mean you could just like
rope her to the chair remember little
German girl yeah they got annalize
McCallie yeah they got recordings of her
[ __ ] speaking weird demonic tongues
and stuff she died during yeah I think
well they did several like over a long
period of time I think it was
dehydration was cause of death I think
yeah she looks starved and she looked
awful yeah we did a show about her a
long time ago right I don't
I don't really know what the situation
was to me it looked like some kind of
weird mental illness or it did yeah it's
hard to say
I think it's what the scientologists
would call what does it break from
reality or what do they call it
when they took a Scientologist and they
put them in solitary until they went
crazy they look like that yeah what was
that called they called it something it
was called a purification rundown I
think that's what they called yeah they
lock you in a room and like they
wouldn't feed you like they'd just give
you like a bunch of weird vitamin
concoctions and not talk to you for
months and you [ __ ] go crazy in that
cell that's what happened to Lisa
McPherson
type deal she even had like cockroach
eating her eating crackers
yeah that was [ __ ] up why she was
alive I can't believe we haven't done we
should do a show about her yeah oh yeah
like I said I I used to work with people
that knew her like and were around like
during that time period and were and
like gave testimony at that trial yeah
so I do I worked with the the woman that
worked there when I worked there that
was a sales manager she was Lisa
McPherson's roommate yeah
so they don't know what happened to her
she was just she was just found running
down the street naked yeah and then they
arrested her and handed her over to the
sign the Doctor Who was a Scientologist
and he gave her right back to the
Scientology and he put it through a
purification rundown which is kind of
like an exorcism and she died yeah
killed her it was [ __ ] up but
I think it killed her because they
didn't give her any water they weren't
going in there and taking care of her
because they were trying she's doing
Special scientologists you don't need
water I don't think you have OT Powers I
don't think that's what the case was I
think what it was is like negligence
they kept doing security shifts watching
her and every time somebody would do a
shift they weren't told to feed or give
them any water
they thought that maybe the ship before
had done it that's what I think what was
going on yeah realized that nobody's
given Ernie water in a button it was hot
in there so they'd probably giving her
water five or six days and I don't think
they knew I think the people Gardener
didn't know dumbasses yeah
but yeah I mean but this cabbage [ __ ]
he was pissed off maybe you [ __ ]
idiots you know you killed her yeah yeah
good job dumbasses if you join a cult
you could be very intelligent but you're
an idiot yeah yeah there's a lot of
intelligence
and it's more of the intelligent people
that join Cults dumb people are like
sharks they know better like I ain't
doing it
but but an intelligent person has an
imagination so you can abuse them
suck them right in with a line and
people have known this forever
psychologists do it all the time to
people that's what psychological warfare
is all about talking you into [ __ ]
defeating yourself you can only do that
to an intelligent person a dumb person
sees right through it because they only
act in their own interest
a person who's trying to act Save the
Planet oh yeah you can get them to
[ __ ] believe all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
that's what Scientology is about
clearing the planet
I don't know a lot of the scientologists
I met when I was over there pretty
stupid uh
yeah because they're raised in that [ __ ]
and they're [ __ ] they're dumb they're
artificially dumb but I think if you
give them an IQ test it'd probably
they'd probably come out pretty good A
lot of them
um
intelligent people fall for Cults oh I
know they do I'm just saying I'm just
saying I I've met a bunch of dumb people
in that [ __ ] too well they're badly
misinformed yeah but you know that's
throughout Society
most people are badly misinformed
you can tell a person anything they go
okay yeah
especially to have authority they
believe authorities
Mark says if somebody starts speaking in
a language they don't know you gotta
wonder what the [ __ ] is going on yeah I
think really that's kind of one of the
main things that
that's one of the tests that they have
to do like yeah that they'll actually do
an exorcism but the person giving the
test do they they might recognize a few
words from another language or do they
actually just think that they're
recognizing see that's what I always
wondered are you bringing in like a
fluent speaker because otherwise you
could just think I think that's French
no she's speaking French and they could
just be like blah blah blah and like and
like some half remembered words from
French class like right because I could
what because I could probably do that I
took I took four years of French back in
high school and I don't remember a lot
about it but you want to bring a fluent
French speaker in and then converse with
that person and then then maybe yeah
right oh and then also you have to like
really look because they always say oh
there's no way that that person could
know how I'm like well is there really
no way that they could have learned to
speak that language at any time it's not
like it's an alien language the
subconscious mind is real powerful it is
yeah you might know a a pretty decent
amount of a foreign language and not in
your sub
don't even know it
that's what I'm saying so it just could
be a thing where
like I said if you learn some like a
long time ago and kind of forgot it but
then you were kind of in a state of mind
where you were just like letting your
subconscious kind of flow freely like
maybe a lot of it would come out
well the the mind is a quantum computer
and uh there's a lot of stuff that's
happening that's not physical it's not
it's not a digital computer it's and
it's not Computing in the way that
we would think computation is about
Stuart hammeroff talks all about it and
Sir pambrose pembrose pem rose right Pen
Rose and Rose yeah like a pen and a rose
yes she gets mad
they're just names names are made up
okay uh I don't yeah but I want you
[ __ ] my I don't want you [ __ ]
people's names
anyway
don't get all into that that the brain
is not Computing in the way that a
digital computer does so these people
with the this AI Singularity people
they're tripping that computer will be
you might be able to get it to mimic a
human mind
to a certain extent but that thing will
never be a living creature it will never
have a feeling of qualia it will never
feel that it exists it'll only be an
illusion
well there's a bunch of stuff happening
inside your subconscious whether that
subconscious is inside the brain or
outside in some kind of quantum field
there's there's stuff happening in that
subconscious that only a quantum
computer could do
you might know a couple of languages and
be unaware of it
that's theoretically possible because
yeah
just for hearing it yeah it might be in
there somewhere because that my your
your unconscious mind mind may have
cracked those codes and already
deciphered what all that [ __ ] means
and can reproduce it to a certain extent
as long as it had heard the word or fake
it slightly it say well it's a Latin
language so this noun will probably be
like this in in Romanian you know or
some [ __ ] like that yeah you know more
than you think you know more than you
think you do you know right so that's
why some of the some of the characters
in your dreams do things that you would
never do and they would say things that
you wouldn't say and sometimes they'll
solve a problem that you wouldn't solve
and you're like well [ __ ] who was that
character what was came out of me it was
in my it came from my mind so your mind
is a lot more powerful than you think a
lot of these Geniuses said that they saw
the mathematical Solutions these massive
equations and problems inside of
theoretical physics they saw it in a
dream
okay well and that happens a lot like if
you have a problem that you're thinking
about like sometimes you'll think of a
solution I mean it happens to a lot of
people yeah so don't underestimate human
mind
and that's kind of why I'm very very
skeptical skeptical of these because you
can't jump to
you know oh this person knows the
language they don't know or they're
doing this kind of stuff therefore
demons exist I'm like that's a whole
other realm demon existence
um there's too many hurdles that you
have to overcome before you can jump to
that you know what I'm saying and like I
said a lot of stuff you know even if you
had to go like Paranormal in the sense
of like you know Poltergeist activity
and [ __ ] like that I would rather just
go there instead of like going way out
on a limb and talking about demons
because like I said that's a whole other
kettle of fish yeah the demon people
tend to be uh religious yeah that's what
I'm saying and in in this country
they're talking about Christianity yeah
the problem with the demon people is
that the the Bible the Old Testament and
the New Testament do not agree on what a
demon is
it'll call
um what you doing poke
she's staring at me it'll call kind of
like uh Fallen Angels it'll call them
demons but then it says other things
later on in the New Testament about what
Jesus casting out basically what they're
describing is The Souls of the Evil Dead
they're saying they're calling them
demons too
but there's a big difference you're a
demon you're you're demon everyone yeah
what's funny is that in the Old
Testament the Fallen Angel story that's
very Mesopotamian that's very Jewish
okay that's their concept of what a
demon is
then you get in the New Testament the
spirits of the Evil Dead angle is a very
Roman concept they're they're two very
different concepts that the evil dead or
demonic
and if that's something you got to worry
about
in the old in the Old Testament they
didn't worry about that because there
was this shio the grave
you know the the underworld and they and
all the dead people were in there
they're
you know there wasn't any hell they
didn't go to hell they didn't even go to
heaven they just went to Shield
only people that went to heaven was like
Methuselah
nothing Noah got taken no no I just got
did Noah get taken
uh
no I think Enoch got taken and I think
Abraham got taken
everybody else just died
there was no reward or punishment really
but people forget that
Kevin Donovan says demon wind go watch
it I've actually seen it I don't
remember it making much of an impression
I remember like shutter added it like a
couple years ago and I remember watching
it maybe I'll watch it again one of
these days it might be on 2B but I don't
remember I kind of remember it but not I
don't remember that much about it
so uh so yeah so they go to Connecticut
which I guess was eight hours away from
wherever the hell they were I think was
in Virginia somewhere
so they go to zappos's house and uh he
says when she got there when Mary got
there he you know she looked at him like
all [ __ ] like with hatred and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so the exorcism
is going to be done by a priest who was
on there talking whose name was fair
father Larry Elward
and he had worked with Zappos for like a
quarter Century at this point so as I
said I'm not sure if this is how it
happened in real life but they basically
just sat her in a chair and then they
had like Jane and Allison and all them
there it's like hey you hold her arms
and we'll hold her legs and stuff I'm
like you know you can't just why don't
you just get some zip ties or something
like that like I don't know why they
would like sit there because she could
punch you or kick you or some [ __ ] like
that or barf on you I don't know but
yeah so they're all like holding her
down
uh also I thought this was kind of
charming this was uh the first time I've
ever seen a musical exorcism I don't
think I've ever seen that they he sang
it like when he first started doing it
because normally like I don't think
they've ever shown this on haunting and
I've never seen this in a movie I mean
I'm sure it's probably better yeah
yeah
it's a musical I was like a musical
actors that would be like that's
delightful it's like something you would
do in an Islamic exorcism too I've seen
them kind of sing yeah I've seen that
kind of stuff but I'd never seen like a
cat I'm sure they do it like I've seen
them do like Catholic mass where they're
like singing and stuff but I never saw
specifically an exorcism that was like
in somebody's house that was like a
sing-song exorcism I'm like oh that's
kind of neat and then they were all kind
of singing along I'm like oh they all
know this song that's kind of cool get
out demons it was like that kind of
thing like that's not what it sounded
like but you know what I mean I just
thought that was kind of you know I just
thought that was really funny again that
was like another thing that like really
struck me as funny I don't know why
certain details in this like strike me
as funny what they do
so yeah musical exorcism
um and at this point like the the priest
said she started reacting really
violently she started saying to Jane I
think that she kept saying I have a
present for you I have a present for you
and I'm like is she gonna barf in her
face because I'm out of here but um I
don't know if they ever said like what
the president was like what she was
talking about I don't know if because
she's like oh like she was gonna take
her to hell or something like that I'm
like that's not a present though like I
don't know it I just thought it was
weird that they harped on that so much
and then I don't think they really like
follow through like with what the
president was because I was like is this
gonna be bad like I said she's gonna
throw up in my face because that's what
it sounded like it was leading up to but
it didn't
so they said so the exorcism was going
on for like an hour
and uh I can't remember it was Jane or
Allison but she the one because they
were both holding like one of her arms
and she said that um basically she said
that that she felt like really strong
like just it felt like she could have
like thrown them across the broom like
when she was struggling and whatnot so
you know all the standard exorcism stuff
ensues she's you know writhing around
and like doing D mini voices and all
that kind of stuff and then they said so
you know the the exorcism goes into like
hour two right and then suddenly Mary
and the chair like she kind of like
relaxes like oh the Demon's gone and
then she kind of like does that little
Grinchy kind of smile and then like her
and the chair like start floating like
up into like so they levitated I don't
know how much it levitated in real life
but I mean it was pretty pretty
impressive like on the show it was
probably like I don't know like three or
four feet like off the floor
um and zappus said you know I've been
doing this [ __ ] for like 33 years and
that was the first levitation that he
had ever seen so like her and the chair
like you know what I mean
um so then like the priest just keeps on
going and like pushing the you know the
cross into her forehead and asking the
Demon's name the demon said he was
Belial and I was like okay that's that's
a pretty that's a pretty big demon right
in Belial kind of like a big I know he's
not he's not just the deformed brother
in the basket and basket case
but I'm pretty sure blyle was like kind
of like a big deal demon but he said
that's what his name was and I guess
like once the demon tells you his name
like you have power over him or somebody
is that how that works I can that's how
it works in the movies so long story
short
too late um it worked in the end and
Mary's basically like the demon left uh
she felt like super happy she said she
felt like a newborn baby uh and that she
could breathe again and fresh her air
and blah blah all the kind of stuff that
you say uh zaphus also said after though
like as a little bit of a warning caveat
he was kind of like um after you know
you've been [ __ ] with by the
Paranormal especially if it's like a
demonie kind of [ __ ] or if it's like
negative then they don't forget who you
are so you always have to like they
always remember you so you always have
to like
you know be on your guard and be
vigilant because they're gonna like
follow you around everywhere and like
try to
again like crawl into your orifices
again if you don't watch them because
you know how they do uh so I mean I
don't know how they do Mary uh basically
gives up paranormal research after that
uh in deference to her son and probably
because it's like yeah we don't want
this [ __ ] happening again so I'm not
going to any paranormal investigations
and getting any more demons like
latching themselves on because that
wasn't a good time
um and basically she said at the very
end she said uh if you can survive
demonic possession I think you can
survive just about anything I'm like
sure words are never spoken like words
to live by words to live by vegans
I don't know so uh so yeah that was um
that was that episode it's a decent
episode it was like I said even though
I'm usually more of like a ghost story
person
um than a demon possession person and
that goes with like these shows and
movies and stuff too yeah there's no way
to debunk this one there's not enough
witness not enough evidence there it's
just testimony and you just gotta take
it at face value that's the story yeah I
mean pretty much that's the story and
you know and and like I said I did like
um this did have like two of the
creepiest scenes like in the whole
series
in it one of them wasn't so much a scene
it was just like the sound design like
because I said that grunty piggy noise
uh that was like really really creepy
and the whole car scene was like really
creepy just because of that actress's
face was like so
spooky we got a lot of intelligent
people in the comment sections mentioned
in the Book of Enoch and all kinds of
scriptural stuff happening in the
Russian Orthodox and mentioned
mentioning uh the gin or genies and
everything so I'm glad you guys are up
on your uh religious mythology you know
I call it mythology not and I say that
with respect I uh I like mythologies and
uh there's a lot of Truth in mythology
but uh it's obvious that if you read any
of those books these are stories
stories to explain things there may be
some truth in it
or at least it was true from their point
of view they're they're telling what
what they thought you know was happening
but uh yeah and then somebody talked
about the Watchers in Book of Enoch
if you watch aronofsky's Noah they're in
there too now I don't know if if the
Book of Enoch you know there's going to
be a bunch of different translations of
it
I don't know if the Book of Enoch called
them the Watchers maybe they did but
probably what they're talking about is
uh God's Sons
the ones other than
um
other than Yahweh
so they're talking about the Bales
Molech and all the other 72 other ones
which is strange because it's the same
amount of virgins that you get when you
go to
Islamic heaven but um they were
cross-breeding with women making Giants
and Nephilim just like in the Greek
mythology make a demigods
so they get imprisoned in the Earth
which they show in that movie and
they're they're trying to seek salvation
so they could get released from the
Earth
which basically you're talking about
extraterrestrials super super beings
from the stars and that's actually kind
of how they're shown in in Darren
aronofsky's Noah that's a great flick
great flick
that's what they're talking about
some people got some religious people
got mad at that but that's I've never
read The Book of Enoch but I've
been told all about it through you know
Dr Price and uh uh seen his
interpretations of certain parts of the
book I know in general some a lot of the
stuff that happens in Enoch
which is part of the Apocrypha it's an
apocryphal text it's not in the Old
Testament but
priests read it back in the day
and uh evidently according to Dr Price
that that story is accurate or the
Darren aronowski movie Noah is accurate
to the Apocrypha
it's a slightly different interpretation
but it's more of a modern interpretation
a lot of religious people got mad that's
not in the Bible no no it's an Enoch
yeah
great movie
Ben says the Jewish name for that book
is the book of Watchers book of Watchers
okay yeah okay yeah
Kevin says we sing a portion of mass in
Latin now I always wait for the
possessed parishioners to go nuts yeah
I'm just saying I knew that they had
like that they sang some of the portions
I just never saw like an exorcism
specifically that they sang before so I
thought that was kind of neat that they
had that on the show where he because I
wasn't expecting it like I was just
expecting your standard like exorcism
behind me saying or whatever the [ __ ]
they say and uh then he just started
singing and I was like oh that's nice
it's funny you guys are talking about
the Watchers in The Book of Enoch and
just kind of dawned on me probably the
reason why
and Chris in Roman early Christianity
demons are spirits of the evil dead and
not fallen angels
is probably because in the Book of Enoch
in The Book of Enoch they were freed
they a lot of them reached salvation
when they helped Noah cause the flood so
it could be that
there's just like there's no mention of
Satan Satan was in heaven
and in the New Testament you just talk
about the dragon and the Antichrist
mostly
so it could be the reason why Roman
Christians said that demons were the
Evil Dead is because
the sons of God
freed from the earth and went back to
Heaven because that's what's shown in
the movie that's probably why
Roman Jews and Roman Christians probably
said no all those guys the Watchers they
all got free
the only demons that are left are the
spirits of the evil dead it's probably
what they're talking about
but only guy who would really know would
be Dr Price or guys that know those
stories real well uh because they're not
really mentioned
yeah because those guys I think all got
freed
we'll see we'll see did you know the
story that well Jen no yeah I think they
all got freed when they when they helped
Yahweh create the create the flood
it's a
I think I think so maybe somebody in the
comment section might know more about it
that's probably what happened so the
Roman Christians and Roman era Jews
probably didn't believe in any about
these uh
um Watchers or Fallen Angels [ __ ] and
chained into the center of the earth
they probably thought they all got
reprieved and sent back to heaven or
space they went back to outer space
where they came from
Ancient Aliens yeah it's Prometheus
basically
Ancient Aliens is what they're talking
about yeah like that crazy Greek guy
with the hair yeah
it came from beyond the stars
yeah Ben says the best part of Noah is
where two Volcan was hiding on the ark
and snacking on random sleepers
a limited amount of those in his eyes
yeah they put them all to sleep and [ __ ]
in there that was a great nugget yeah
two volcanes
yeah see that like explained it's like
why like they didn't all the animals
didn't eat each other like in the ark
they're like we put them all into like
hypersleep yeah you know what I mean
yeah just like if you were going to like
didn't someone get smaller
or was that another one I think they got
small too and so it became more compact
yeah yeah it's like a storm but but you
know yeah they used [ __ ] magic god
Magic
they could do like Dr pretorius and
Brian Frankenstein and like make them
all really little and like put them in
little jars yeah and there wasn't two
and then put water on them and like both
it wasn't like people messing up that
there was like male and female tube no
it's it says that what is it there's
two or three and it's again it says two
different things in some passages I
think it says four pairs or five pairs
of the clean animals and three pairs of
the unclean animals I don't remember
filthy animals there's a bunch of them
of each type of animal clean or unclean
there was more than two there was a
small breeding population I thought I
just saw like a bug or something like
fly in front of the yeah every now and
then we're gonna net in here I don't
know what that was it was really light
it's fruit fly time little bitty gnats
oh yeah okay maybe that's what it was
yeah or it was a demon it was a demon
being like it's gonna come in here and
like fly up my nose it's like oh you
don't believe in me huh
yelling at the fan okay
all right are we are we done talking
about because I guess I made some to eat
what you gonna make
gotta finish up the taco meat oh okay
that's fine okay Taco sounds good all
right yeah we've been we went for an
hour and a half like I said we went on
like twice as long as the actual episode
yeah because we were like talking about
some other [ __ ]
Kevin said Kevin said I wish there was a
Catholic event where you could bring
someone you suspect to be possessed to
do like a demonic cross check
maybe like going to like [ __ ]
AutoZone and getting her to do a thing
like where your check engine light is on
but it's like your check possession like
that would be that would be [ __ ] yeah
and then saying that it sounds a lot
like the Titans from the great yeah it
does because they had to get rid of the
Titans and then the new govs came in
they were playing a lot of that
the the the
[Music]
um
if you look at like uh the Jewish
Pantheon or the proto-jewish pantheon
the people that were writing this [ __ ]
like back from the septuagen area era
we're not modern it was not the modern
Jewish religion it was the old Jewish
religion and it was more like kind of
like the hillbilly version of the Greek
pantheon they all worship the same Gods
including the the the Greeks and the the
Greeks and the Persians worship the same
Gods back in those days so they were all
basically the same Pantheon they just
gave different names to them you know El
Shaddai means father of the Gods they're
talking about Zeus Greece would have
just called him Zeus the El shaddai's
wife was [ __ ]
uh ashara who is a sir a woman would
holding two serpents
and later she gets demoted to a serpent
herself in the story but that's Hera
they're talking about Hera you know and
then his sons his main sons and then all
the kids
that they created knocking up Mortal
women that's it's the you know the
demigods you know in in in in in the
Jewish Pantheon it was called you know a
men of great Renown and uh what do you
call a Nephilim you know Samson and
Hercules when I heard this moments like
a Jesus but Goliath and Samson you know
the giant men of great Renown they're
[ __ ] Nephilim that they're talking
about
the Greeks would call them demigods
but it's that same concept
you know
all right so we're gonna wrap it up
because we went on for an hour and a
half yeah tomorrow we're gonna do
another Universal movie we're gonna do
the OG Dracula yeah talk about the Bella
lagosi Dracula from 1931 we're gonna
watch that tonight and we'll talk about
it tomorrow at 6 PM Eastern Standard
Time now we're gonna go get some tacos
yeah so have a good rest of your evening
you guys yeah I responded to bed yeah
you got a bed you know what I'm talking
about yeah in his comments yeah and
we'll see you guys again tomorrow
evening good night